Now let's analyze the security of the
Diffie-Hellman key exchange algorithm.
First, we observe that the shared key,
meaning the shared secret,
that is computed by both users A and
B, itself is never transmitted.
Further, the local secret of user A or
B itself is also not transmitted.
That is, the local secret,
XA, is kept to user A, and
the local secret, XB, is kept to user B.
In summary,
no secret value is being transmitted.
On the other hand, the values you and
YB are transmitted.
Then the question is from you which is
alpha raised to the power of XA mod q.
And given that alpha and q and
you are known can
an emissary compute xa?
The security assumption here,
is that this grid algorithm when large
number is involved is very hard.
That is given y, alpha, and
q, it is extremely hard to
compute the value of x, or
it is not practical to compute x.
Because q is a very large prime.
For example, q is a least 300 bit long.
On the other hand,
if this conjecture is not true,
that means an adversary knowing you and
knowing alpha and q,
can easily compute xa which is
the local secret to user a.
This would mean that
the adversary can compute
secret key as they're shared between
user A and B, just like user A.
Because now, the adversary knows
the local secret of user A.